lies of p is a Soul's leg with a very
mysterious Story one that will be
attempting to uncover throughout this
video along with critiquing the quality
of its story along the way very quickly
before we begin thanks to Neo Wiz and
round 8 studio for providing me a code
early allowing me to play the game
before release and as always spoiler
warning ahead we're going to be talking
about this game's story and endings in
this video so please be sure to complete
the game before you watch this if you
like this kind of story analysis content
feel free to check out my other videos
here on the channel I don't just have
videos on the souls games and some Souls
likes but other genres as well so feel
free to stick around
with that out of the way though let's
get started
the beginning of the game starts with a
blue butterfly Reviving someone called
Geppetto's puppet will then learn that
not only is the butterfly being
controlled by a girl named Sophia but
that we also have a talking qriket
companion inside of a lamp called Gemini
the references are pretty on the nose
but it's to be expected as if he didn't
catch it let me tell you now that Liza p
is a reimaging of the original story of
Pinocchio that's why the very beginning
pays respects to Carlo carlotti as he
was the one who created the 1880 fantasy
novel The Adventures of Pinocchio the
references here are just the tip of the
iceberg however as many characters and
bosses in this game reference their
novel counterparts for example in the
novel Pinocchio is followed by a talking
qriket that advises and AIDS him just
like Gemini does to us and Sofia is
related to the Blue Fairy from the novel
who in the text was the one who granted
Pinocchio's nose diabody to extend
whenever he lied she was described as a
young woman with turquoise hair which
fits the bill of our Sofia not all the
characters are direct references as
others are just using the characters
names like puccinella the butler of
anini who in the novel shares the name
of a marionette that's performing at a
theater I will admit this idea is what
drew me to Liza p in the first place
Souls like tend to be very samey after a
while as most just have items with
descriptions and then place them in a
generic Fantasy World Under Siege from
something it's not very Innovative
especially nowadays what a Soul's like
based on a children's fairy tale is
certainly a nice change of pace and even
when the game falls into those
aforementioned fantasy elements and
continues to stay in its Lane and keep
things centered around the Avengers of
Pinocchio say what you feel about lies
of P it's distinctly unique and really
separates itself from the rest of the
genre with that being said anytime a
character appears with some amount of
relevance to the novel I'll be sure to
point them out
returning to the story while we don't
have a name as the game never provides
us with one it's safe to assume the
puppet's name is Pinocchio which is how
I'll be referring to them from now on
Pinocchio is instructed by Sofia to go
to the nearby hotel to arm himself as
the puppets along the way are dangerous
to set the scene Liza P takes place in
the city of crot this place used to be a
small fishing Village for the discovery
of Ergo in-game ergoes what we collect
upon defeating enemies in what we use to
level up this substance threw crot into
a golden age as it was able to enter
into a technological Revolution the
people responsible for most of the work
behind cross new life is a group called
The Alchemists their leader was one
valentius who was able to understand and
channel the energy of Ergo allowing him
and his group to create completely new
technology one such Tech was the
creation of the puppets these autonomous
beings are designed to do whatever they
were made to some of them were workers
and maids and others were Butlers and
policemen this gave Humanity the chance
to take a hands-off approach to numerous
parts of their life allowing the puppet
City would for them the maker of these
puppets was a Craftsman known as
Geppetto who was one of the most
well-known members of the workshop the
mass production all this new technology
was in Handle by laurenzini vanini and
with his Newfound partnership crott was
able to flourish that was until a puppet
killed a human
a puppet named arlochino who is the same
puppet who gives us all the riddles kill
benini's parents just to see what would
happen this would have caused a
Monumental backlash for everyone
involved so they decided to try and
cover up the mystery by claiming that it
was a mugging instead of a murder
leading people to believe that it was a
human and not a puppet this incident
made Geppetto realize that commands
needed to be hard-coded into the puppet
so they could prevent more deaths as
such each puppet has four basic
principles imprinted into them called
the Grand Covenant these are obey the
commands of the Creator never heard a
human protect and serve crot and its
people and never lie Geppetto with the
help of anini was successful in creating
a code of law that the puppets are
forced to abide by however that didn't
seem to last as the puppets have clearly
gone Madden are attacking this city as
such a group of Vigilantes known as
stalkers have been dispatch in order to
stop them while the stalkers are all the
same the people they serve as with the
difference lies the two groups are the
bastards in the sweepers the bastards
aren't the Alchemists in the workshop
while the sweepers Ally themselves the
old families of cropped they don't get
much mention in this game but the old
families of crott are obviously the
older families that used to own the city
but due to the discovery of Ergo and the
power it came with thanks to The
Alchemist in the workshop they've been
in close competition ever since this
whole Fiasco regarding the puppets is
also known in game as the puppet frenzy
and it's our job to stop it but that's
quite the Herculean task so we're gonna
start small and figure out where
Geppetto is and then hopefully rescue
him before any danger comes his way this
is where the gameplay comes in and
starts to flex its wings a bit I won't
talk too much about the gameplay but I
do at least want to go over the basics
for those of you who haven't played it
basically it's a Souls game I can't even
say that as a joke either as just about
everything in the souls games is here
too bonfires Estes flasks backstab
stagger bar the fact that jump is only
able to be used while sprinting it's
pretty much all here and honestly
borders on the line of plagiarism at
times especially since Pinocchio's
Legion arms are basically Wolf's
prosthetic arms both in design and
functionality the game does attempt to
try and introduce new mechanics to
separate itself but most of the combat
is pretty much one to one if you've
played a Souls game which may or may not
be a good thing depending on how you
feel about them circling back to where
we left off while we explore the train
station we learned from a couple of
notes the city is bracing for Resurgence
of the petrification disease it's
unclear where this came from and how it
started but the disease petrifies those
it affects by hardening their skin and
is something that's going to keep
popping up every now and again
throughout the game but for now let's
focus on the frenzy as we can see the
town is already in shambles with the
deadline in the streets while the
puppets aimlessly wait for their next
Target due to the nature of the frenzy
it's natural to call into question
Pinocchio and why he wasn't affected
well it seems to stem from Geppetto he
made Pinocchio for a very specific
reason one which we'll get to later but
you can tell that he's different as he
has the ability to lie a common
predicament the player will have in this
game is whether to lie about a certain
event to an NPC such as this woman who
wants us to find her baby when we go to
the instructed location we find no
survivors but we do find a doll and
seeing as the old woman is losing her
sight due to the petrification we can
tell her that the doll is her daughter
and she would be none the wiser most of
the choices are like this but with
various different circumstances I did
initially like the concept but the
choices felt a bit undercooked as these
choices don't really matter lying or
telling the truth in this game only
result in a change of dialogue is you
still get the same rewards the primary
reason is that it's not what the lies
are that matters but whether or not you
decided to lie in the first place lying
and telling the truth enough times will
decide the ending and while that's fine
I think the occasional consequence could
have been interesting either way once
you have managed to make through the
first set of Puppets including the boss
of the area the parade Master you'll
make it to the hotel where we're
introduced to our base of operations and
the title screen as introductions go
Liza P starts off quite well there's
enough mystery surround in the world
that it makes you want to uncover its
Dark Secrets although at least for me a
lot of that came from the Intrigue of
Pinocchio's history it'd be quite
foolish to make a story about Pinocchio
and at least not take into consideration
what makes that character so special and
as I said Liza P does excel at keeping
that idea in Mind by letting you deal
with certain moral quandaries and seeing
how these conversations shape our boy
quite literally in some ways
for a new release that really has to
focus on Exposition and details that the
audience can be caught up to speed while
also giving the player enough time to
get a feel for the gameplay I think
lizapi does a great job bringing the
player into the world of crot
inside the hotel is a group of guests
who are taking Refuge from the
destruction the one with the most
importance is Sophia or as I like to
call her lady Ronnie which now that I
think about it is rather funny given
Ronnie was a puppet in that game either
way lunar princess Ronnie here tells us
that while we do likely have questions
about what's going on what's more
important is finding Geppetto as he'll
be able to answer any of the questions
we have so we head off to Elysian
Boulevard to find him along the way
we'll also run into a stalker called The
Mad donkey he is seen right outside
Geppetto's Carriage attempting to get in
because he wants to find out why all of
his friends were killed by the puppets
so naturally he goes to Geppetto for
some answers we managed to stop him
before he goes too far though but we can
see if this whole disaster is really
taking a toll on everyone we'll end up
seeing a few more examples like this
throughout the game and I really think
it's one of the game's strongest aspects
it's one thing to say that there's a
disaster but another two actually show
it and while the game does do that
through its excellent environmental
storytelling having NPCs do the job
instead allows for more emotion to come
through really Hammer home how badly
this whole thing has become
unfortunately Geppetto isn't in the mood
to talk because of course he isn't so we
have to do one more thing before we can
get some answers and that's getting rid
of the puppets at City Hall the boss of
this new location is the scrapped
Watchman a giant puppet policeman from
the relevant item descriptions we
learned that this specific puppet was a
mascot of sorts many people came to
enjoy the puppet's company and thanked
it for keeping the city safe its life
would be cut short however as it was
equipped with an overcharged storage
battery that exceeded its capacity
causing a chain explosion that damaged
most of its body and internal systems as
a result it was going to be disposed of
but benini wanted to test some
experiments on it to see how far they
could push their technology for some odd
reason though it was still able to
perform some of its mascot roles and is
still very popular with the children in
fact its boss Soul item description says
the Walla was contorted and broken from
the adult's desires he never forgot the
children who considered him a friend
it's a very heartwarming story for a
horrific of a game as this is but not
only does it show how much the puppets
have affected the people of Croft as
they started seeing some of them as
mascots but more importantly how some of
the puppets are starting to show emotion
puppets realistically are just machine
games they don't have any complex
thoughts and feelings like humans do but
this publicly cared about the kids he
even kept a doll that they made of him
on his person at all times it's this
idea of Puppets displaying more
human-like emotions that continues to be
brought up throughout the game but for
now it's just used as an introduction in
an interesting showcase foreshadowing
the events to come
with that over though we can now talk to
Geppetto who was elated to see his son
but also understands that work still
needs to be done Sue sends us off on
another mission which is to liberate a
few places and crowd from public control
these are vanini works the same for
Angelico Cathedral the malam district
and Rosa Isabelle Street sadly the game
does not really offer as much Freedom as
it sounds as while we do get to visit
all these locations over time the map is
pretty linear so we're forced to go
through a set order starting with venini
and his Workshop vanity Works
mass-produces puppets so as long as the
puppets have control of the facility
they have access to unlimited
reinforcements which is more than enough
reason to put it out of business the
workshop is another good look at the
horrors of this world thanks to this
area's boss admittedly it's not super
important but it is a scary sign of how
Obsessed the people of krot were with
the puppets some of the puppets who
fight throughout this game are massive
one slight malfunction and these things
could kill someone but this thing is
absurd obviously the puppets were not
designed to kill people but it really
starts to put things into perspective
when you realize that they most
definitely can kill people they're just
being held back by a code of law a code
that is also not currently working it's
a classic tale of humanity being overly
greedy with technology and then paying
the price for it but this puppet is
where I really started to appreciate the
design of these enemies as yeah the
variety isn't super impressive but the
designs of them are each of them is
incredibly distinct and you could tell
immediately what they were made to do
just by their designs and we're never
told what this thing's purpose is but
given its size in the two giant balls
for hands this puppet was likely a
replacement for Wrecking Ball
construction vehicles on the topic of
that lizapee rarely delves into the
impact of having this many puppets and
how this could affect the workers as
from what I can tell most people are
actually pretty happy with them despite
the fact that numerous puppets are
realistically designed to take people's
jobs it's kind of an unfortunate mishap
as I don't recall ever meeting anyone in
this game who's annoyed at the puppet's
existence that being said it does end up
working out well narratively but in a
different way as while the people of
crot don't Harbor negative feelings
towards these inventions they do
sensationalize them everyone in the city
loves these things and it's causing lots
of the public opinion to be centered
around them which is why there's such
demand for these things that's also why
the new design designs have to be bigger
and better like the giant puppet we just
talked about or this thing that looks
like a smaller version of an armored
Cormac it's almost like the inventors
are saying a robot with two giant drills
and saws for hands [__] it let's send it
to the assembly team and it's this
greedy attitude that would be the city's
downfall as their greatest asset has
become their greatest nightmare but of
course while some would see This
Disaster and develop some humility from
it the greedy CEO himself anini isn't
too concerned he's scared for his life
sure but the way he talks almost pisses
me off at times like how he calls krot
his City or how he never wastes a moment
to gloat about what he's accomplished
and what he's done to deserve his spot
in life what makes it worse is that he's
not the only person who's focused on
themselves here although this other
lot's reasoning makes a lot more sense
nearby is a Duo of stalkers named red
fox and black cat they were originally
hired by venini to take care of the
puppet at the base of the factory but
backed out once they realized the job
was way above their pay grade these
Schmucks are probably one of the most
annoying people in the game as they
always Force us to do all the work such
as later when we're going to take down
the black rabbit my brotherhood and the
two offered to join but after going
about 30 feet the cat goes oh sorry mate
I gotta take a breather uh go on ahead
won't you and then they leave forcing us
to take them down ourselves while both
of them are borderline and competent at
times it mirrors their original roles in
the novel as it's mentioned that a cat
and a fox would constantly harass
Pinocchio by stealing or tricking him
every time they meet the duo we've been
tried to hang him at one time but he's a
puppet so oxygen isn't really a
necessity for him the game also carries
over the blindness bit from the story as
the two animals lie about being disabled
in order to con Pinocchio into giving
them money but by the end of the story
they actually become the things they
lied about and Liza P the black hat
actually seems to be going blind already
and asks us for fruits that he can ease
the pain speaking of which quite a few
NPCs and bosses in this game end up
suffering Fates that they wished upon
other people instead of it being about
the city and its greedy attitude towards
Evolution through technology the
characters usually suffer in different
kinds of greed whether it be the literal
desire of wealth or wanting something
that's not yours and once again it's
another example of this game's
impressive Message In theme foreign
anyway this puppet that the duel refuses
to kill is Fuoco who is also a reference
to the novel although azana's directors
are two stalkers Fuoco is Mangia furoko
from the novel who in this story got
pissed to Pinocchio for ruining his
puppet show and his payment decided to
use him as firewood for his dinner as
you can see that's not anything like our
puppet furnace here but the usage of
fires with the connection lies as for
Fuoco the puppet he's in charge of the
Furnace down here and Benin wants us to
defeat him and also check to make sure
his Butler puccinella is safe something
interesting about this boss though is
that multiple pieces of lore refer to
some kind of king of Puppets that fuelco
worships you can even see him talk about
it in this garbled speech that you can
sorta make out both of these are
connected though so we'll talk about
this later but once again this is
another strange example of the puppets
not doing it they were designed to do we
have a police officer who's growing
feelings for humans and other crowning
Kings none of it makes sense in the
slightest but reinforces what I talked
about earlier how Liza p is really good
at piling on the Intrigue and slowly but
surely feeding you a breadcrumb trail of
info
past the factory is Moonlight town a
rundown place that used to be the start
of the people's pilgrimages when they
were heading to the cathedral Moonlight
also collaborated with the current
Archbishop of the cathedral Andreas as
both locations became colleagues over
time so Andreas would help the people of
moonlight in any way he could and in
turn the town would spread the word of
his Good Deeds as you would expect
though the town is vacant thanks to the
puppets running wild and killing
everyone but once you reached the cable
car that takes us to the cathedral we're
greeted by a horrifying creature with
blue blood all over its body as we'll
soon see the entire Cathedral is overrun
by these things and size and symptoms
seem to vary constantly as if the
monster is going to get any more
terrifying we find one of the biggest so
far who is our next boss Archbishop
Andreas himself
gross would be putting it mildly the man
is hideous but given his related
appearance to the other monsters we can
assume the same thing happened to him
according to the legend same for
Angelico met with a One-Winged Angel and
founded a church with his name on it
it's unclear how long ago that meeting
was but eventually same Frangelico would
pass away and someone be appointed as
the head of the church in the modern day
that person is Archbishop Andreas he was
such a kind and good-hearted person that
many people believed he was Frangelico
himself but that's just what the public
sees as underneath all that is a greedy
Archbishop who is unable to acknowledge
how corrupt he was becoming so he made
up a lie so that he was chosen by a
One-Winged Angel too well as a way of
karmic Justice Andreas became the thing
he made up he became a One-Winged Angel
at least appearance wise anyway judging
by his death dialogue though he seems to
have regretted this and wished that he
could just return to the old hymn before
the greed came this is likely referring
to a diary of his which talks about his
meeting with the Alchemists Andreas
claimed that the Alchemists were ruining
crotch and that they should have been
Cast Away when they arrived all those
years ago further saying that This
Disaster was divine punishment and that
crowded City blessed by God and one that
Andreas will do his best to save this
couple with the monsters we saw in the
church is really starting to point to
The Alchemist being the core of the
problems here in krot at this point
though all we know is that the
Alchemists are trying to figure out how
to stop the puppet frenzy but seeing as
we haven't seen any of them all game
this is likely a lie
moving on though once Andreas is
defeated we see a quick cutscene that is
obviously of our main villain before
going behind the cathedral to the path
of the pilgrim which leads right to the
malum District sadly there isn't much to
say about the malam district except the
fact that it's a fairly poor and run
down District within krot given its
close proximity to the church Andreas
likely tried to help them as much as he
could but he can only do so much both
puppets and monsters now stalk the
streets of these places but the main
antagonist of the area are the black
rabbit Brotherhood we saw them earlier
in the game but this is our first
official meeting with the group we also
get to meet with the stalkers again we
saw back of anini's workshop and it's
here where they have that conversation
about us joining forces and then bailing
almost immediately it would have
actually been nice if they helped too as
the group gangs up on you throughout the
fight they also don't drop a boss Soul
this time as the fight only ends when
the big brother dies but from what we
can gather they're also a group of
stalkers but not like the bastards of
the sweepers the only answers themselves
it's a bit light on the details at least
when it comes to other bosses that we've
already discussed but that's mainly
because they'll return a bit later for a
second round having said that we can see
from their various journals that they
are and talks with the Alchemists as
they have a ledger that details some of
their recent business transactions one
of the notes talks about a gold coin
tree which is this giant tree behind
their base it said that the trees fruit
is able to cure any kind of disease
possible we'll actually be able to use
this tree to help alleviate some of the
pain lady Antonia is going through due
to the petrification any new MPC giongio
also wants us to help him find the tree
the door behind the tree also leads
right back into the hotel which makes me
wonder why no one mentioned this and why
they didn't just open the door from the
hotel side
but sure inside the Brotherhood base
though is also a painting of Pinocchio
which is strange if we take it back to
Geppetto he thanks us for the painting
but he doesn't mention that Pinocchio is
on it he just says that this is a memory
of his from a happier time you would
think the two would talk about this but
he just brushes it aside which is a
little odd but something I will come
back around later after their talk
Geppetto tells us that lady Antonia has
the key to Rosa Isabelle Street which is
what we'll need to get to the king of
puppets and hope we stop this frenzy
once for all Rosa Isabelle is a
well-known Entertainment District within
krot its most famous resident is Adelina
corday the singer in the red dress we
can actually meet Adelina along with her
sister Patricia Patricia had always
wanted to sing with her sister as her
dream was to one day be on the same
Grand stage together Adelina on the
other hand may have not shared that same
dream she says that she wanted her
sister's voice and would do anything to
get it well one day she had her drink
poison which ruined her Golden Voice
allowing Adelina to take Center Stage
for the rest of her career it's a really
sad tale as the sisters exchange lockets
with each other and you can tell that
Patricia really loved her sister but has
no idea that love wasn't reciprocated
back as she doesn't even know about her
sister poisoning her this is also why we
fight Patricia as she decided to become
a stalker due to her singing career
basically being over so in a roundabout
way her death is on adelina's hands not
ours the main reason we're here though
is not for the prima donna but for the
king of Puppets himself but once we
arrive at the theater we see a play
being performed by some of the puppets
which shows Geppetto taking out
Pinocchio's heart and putting it into
another puppet this most certainly will
not be relevant later
afterwards the king of Puppets arrives
to do battle but after killing him we
see another being inside challenges
called Romeo once Romeo dies though
we're then given a necklace as a reward
that says to Romeo from your friend C to
spoil it ahead of time C is referring to
Carlo or more specifically our Pinocchio
here that boy in the painting is Carlo
but we aren't technically Carlo we're a
puppet that looks like him Carlo is the
real son of Geppetto that's why Geppetto
cares so much about Pinocchio as he's a
spitting image of his son who passed
away but if Romeo is the king then why
did he start the puppet frenzy well he
may not have his boss Soul says that one
day he woke up on a throne that wasn't
his implying he was just forced into
this King position furthermore at some
point in the game vanity gives us an
ergo wave decoder which is what we use
to figure out how the frenzy started and
we learned that Romeo was communicating
through Ergo waves or for a lack of a
better word Bluetooth to communicate
with the other puppets across the city
he did this because he discovered what
the Alchemists were up to and wants to
stop them before they achieve their goal
unfortunately we didn't learn about the
Alchemists in their plan until later
after Romeo has already died he also
used this to communicate with us as
Romeo actually wanted us to join him and
had sent Messengers to recruit us which
were all the puppet bosses we just
defeated do you remember those garbled
subtitles that appeared during these
fights while they also appear here and
if you look closely enough you could
pick out some of the words to summarize
they basically talk about Romeo or how
Romeo wants Pinocchio to join them if
it's too hard to read though on New Game
Plus the text is actually clear which is
a nice touch that's why the king extends
his hand to us Romeo has no intention of
fighting he only did that as a last
resort Romeo doesn't just see Pinocchio
as another puppet but also a dear friend
which is another now to the novel since
Romeo and Pinocchio were also friends
there too both versions of the character
also have the nickname lamwick as well
but that still doesn't explain who
started the frenzy well he clears that
up too
within the Ergo waves was a message for
us that says that Geppetto was the cause
of the frenzy that's because Geppetto
created a fifth law called law zero that
says the Creator's name is Geppetto
meaning that while the puppets will obey
their creators and Masters Geppetto's
command specifically overrules them
unfortunately we can't speak to him
about this as this conversation happens
way later in the game after Geppetto is
kidnapped on the hotel but I figured I
should bring this up now since we're
talking about Romeo even without that
conversation though Geppetto and his
motivations haven't exactly been clear
so it's always been useful to watch her
back around him this is just further
confirmation to keep doing just that
turning back the clock to when we
defeated the king of Puppets once we
walk outside the theater we find
Geppetto who's out back waiting for us
with the puppet King dead the remaining
puppets will have no way to operate as
tactically as before which means the
only thing left to do is to figure out
how to cure the petrification disease
and for that Geppetto wants us to go to
the Grand exhibition and meet with the
Alchemists as they're supposedly
developing a cure for it along the way
we'll find some of the puppets mourning
over the loss of their King further
showing that these puppets aren't just
robotic pieces of wood and metal
that said it just seems to be this
location as the other areas both before
and after this have the puppets behave
just like before to be fair I can
forgive this as it would make the
puppet-controlled areas a breeze to
complete thus ruining the point of the
challenging gameplay once we make it to
the Grand exhibition we can see that
this place was used to Showcase all the
new technology that was being developed
for crot there are various different
types of robots and puppets including
that puppet of the Future boss we fought
earlier as well some other designs for
the other Industries within krot what's
odd though is that some of the designs
say volunteers wanted and most of the
equipment here is gurneys along with
dozens of humanoid beings that look
mangled this one in particular has
numerous bandages in cloth wrapped
around it like they were just being
detained everything here points to human
experimentation by the way of The
Alchemist and this is all but confirmed
by the area's boss Victor the champion
he used to be a circus performer who was
seen as the Pinnacle of Humanity's
abilities he was loved by many within
crot until he was stricken with an
incurable illness however thanks to The
Alchemist he was able to live again and
beat his Peak indefinitely so it's clear
that the Alchemists have been conducting
experiments on humans and if you were
still somehow skeptical about it the
leader of the Alchemist Simon Monas
straight up tells us that yeah that's
exactly what he was doing he claims that
the petrification disease can actually
strengthen humanity and by overcoming it
the human body can grow stronger and
gain a mind free of Lies this is all
possible thanks to Ergo as Ergo is
basically the essence of a person's life
force and memory but trapped in a
crystallized form thanks to the
petrification disease hardening the body
Ergo was also put into the core of all
the puppets which is why some of them
started Awakening their egos polandina
for example despite being a puppet is in
love with Lady Antonia we could also
find a note that talks about a woman
named Camille who was likely the first
ever puppet to awaken her ego despite
her initial design being quite basic she
was able to quickly save a child from
falling out of a crib which shocked some
of the Alchemists according to their
notes it seems like a puppet's ego has a
possibility of Awakening faster if the
human the Ergo belongs to is in a
similar role Camille for example was a
maid puppet meaning she was likely a
maid before dying which is why her
maidly instincts kicked in during that
moment from Camille the Alchemists
discovered that Ergo isn't just a simple
Crystal but something that can open the
door to eternal life
Simon in The Alchemist goal from then on
was to achieve immortality and they
believe the Ergo is the way to do it
after this Simon bids us farewell as he
welcomes us to his Island so we can see
what the true Evolution will look like
to get there though we need to go to the
baron Swan there's venini says that a
rare piece of golden Ergo we needed to
make it to the island
the baron swamp is well a swamp because
of course a game like this has to have
one but it's also a Dumping Ground for
other discarded puppets that the city
doesn't use anymore as you can imagine
that is a lot of unused Ergo and thanks
to that one of The Alchemist
experimental Creations was able to Feast
on this Ergo and grow in size and
strength the green monster of the swamp
is that creation and like Andreas is
quite hideous the green monster is
likely reference to the green fisherman
who in the tail was going to cook
Pinocchio thinking he was some kind of
rare fish before being saved by a
Mastiff known as alidoro and here aledor
does the complete opposite and has a
speed beige while he fetches an item the
monster took a long time ago which
actually fits in line without alidoral
ax around this time the player will
likely encounter an earthquake which
from large spikes of blue crystals that
have completely overtaken the city of
crot along with the monsters thanks to
what's killing Romeo the puppets that
were initially holding back the monsters
weren't able to causing more of them to
flood into the streets nearby is also
the workshop Tower with a boss inside
called The Waker of Illusions there's a
lore document nearby that mentions
Victor implying that all this happened
recently saying that Victor was
incomplete and that this person will be
the owner of the complete Elixir which
is what Simon is trying to perfect so
that he can evolve Humanity after its
defeat Sofia contacts us and says the
hotel is under attack and upon arriving
we see that Geppetto has been kidnapped
by the black Brotherhood our stalker Duo
and alidoro I know I kind of brushed
past him a second ago but elidoro is
someone we come across when exploring
the cathedral he claims to be a treasure
hunter and a stalker but through some
conversations with other people we
learned that this person was actually
just a friend of alidoros who end up
getting into an argument with him and
killed them as a result this friend then
took his costume imposes the famous
aledora the one who saved all the people
in the workshop thankfully though
everyone is alive including the hotel
cat who is arguably the most important
member of the hotel
from here we are told to play a certain
chord on the piano in order to gain
access to a secret entrance it leads to
the relic of Tres Magistas as it's the
only way to get inside the Isle of the
Alchemists so once again lady Antonia
has a key but doesn't tell us look I
know you're likely senile already but
help me help you you know at the bottom
of this level are the black rabbit
Brotherhood who want to challenge us
again it's pretty similar to the
previous fight and as such there isn't
much to talk about except that halfway
through the fight the older brother
comes back but looks a lot more like
Victor from the grand exhibition The
Alchemist seemed to found a way to
revive the eldest brother which is kind
of horrifying if you think about it
behind them is where alidoro is
stationed and where he confesses to
killing alidor and then impersonating
him the reason he participated in the
kidnapping at the hotel was because the
Alchemist promised to get him out of the
city if they succeeded in fact all the
stalkers were given the same promise
however we end up meeting with all of
them throughout this section so we'll
never know if the Alchemists were
actually going to make good on their
promise with the Brotherhood finally
dead Nothing is Stopping Us from getting
to the island except Pinocchio's driving
as he beaches the entire submarine
instead of just resurface using it
waiting for us on the beach is Sofia
here is where she reveals to us that her
real body is not the one at the hotel as
her real body is actually at the top of
the Alchemist Tower earlier she told us
that the reason she woke us up was to
save krot which is a fairly reasonable
thing to do but she lied as she only
revived us to save her Sofia is the
daughter of valentius the original
leader of the Alchemist Simon Monas was
valentius's right-hand man but when
Simon took over things started to change
around this time Sofia was also able to
awaken her ergo Powers which is
described as manipulating time she ended
up becoming so well versed with these
powers that Simon kept her here as his
tool due to this she wants us to kill
her once we find her she suffered enough
and just wants peace now to get to where
she's at though we need to cross the
beach which he says is filled with
memories thanks to the Ergo flowing
through the area these memories we see
are of Carlo and Romeo before they died
and were replaced with puppets the two
of them grew up together in the monad
charity house Sophia likely knows of the
boys too as Sophia's last name is monad
and there was a flyer with her name
written on it for the charity house the
two of them would then meet with a
legendary stock and asked if they could
train with her she says no one tells
Gemini to tell them off this either
means that Gemini was also a stalker or
at the very least human which might
explain the bloodstain surrounding him
when we first meet or Germany was always
a cricket but worked with the stalker
unfortunately lots of the details are
unknown as we don't hear anything else
about Gemini and we also don't know how
Carlo died but we obviously know that he
dies because Pinocchio was made to look
like him
upon arriving at the tower we now begin
the slow descend up which almost feels
like padding at this point given how
long it takes to climb plus I was
already 30 hours into the playthrough at
this point to make matters worse there
are also three more boss fights or one
if you play your cards right the red fox
and the black cat are here at the tower
and tells us that Simon promised them a
way out of the city if they cooperated
she doesn't care about Simon's promise
though as she just wants to be with her
brother if we give both of them gold
coin fruit this prevents us from
fighting them if we refuse then we have
to battle according to their equipment
though it seems like the black cat was
an orphan and I convinced the red fox
that he was her brother over time though
he felt really bad about lying her and a
part of him actually wished that it was
true because she really cared for him
the red fox belonged to a family of high
society if the clothing didn't give it
away but she seems to have left and
distance herself from then due to her
brother who as we know isn't actually
her brother for annoying as these two
can be they do really have a touching
story attached to them and honestly I
couldn't really see myself fighting them
mainly because of the aforementioned
problem of me being 30 hours in and just
wanting to hit credits but honestly they
weren't really bad people unlike alidoro
they presumably haven't murdered anyone
and anything they did they could have
been malicious was probably just to save
the other
speaking of devoting your life to
protecting someone the one boss we can't
skip is lacksasia Simon's guard like
seija is completely covered in metallic
armor and easily wins best boss design
in the game according to her boss so
Alexis you used to be a woman called
Adriana but after being baptized by The
Elixir she became the first whole being
the only thing that was different about
her was that her feelings for Simon can
never be erased so she decided to become
the guard in metal armor sworn to
protect Simon until her death
behind her is Sophia's room and yeah I
can kind of see what she wanted us to
kill her still we are given the option
to keep her alive if we're that sadistic
if we do kill her we get gray hair which
is an interesting reward but this is the
only time this happens
if you lie enough times throughout the
game Sofia will speak to you and then
all of a sudden you have long hair
gameplay wise is just a neat cosmetic
but narratively it's meant to show the
Pinocchio is changing into a human as
puppet hair doesn't grow just like all
the decisions though what you do doesn't
really matter if she ends up dying
shortly after anyway it's a real shame
honestly because that same thing happens
with Lady Antonia as regardless of
whether or not you chose the Cure she
still dies the only difference that she
gives you a letter thanking you for
making her final moments happier I'm not
saying it has to affect the main story
but just something anything would have
been nice the other person who's been
captured in the tower is Geppetto who we
can tell off for being a bad father but
all that changes is a line of dialogue
at the very top is none other than Simon
Manas who is starting to look like
Solomon Grundy Simon's history is
fascinating his motivation is less so
Simon's writing seemed to imply that his
father was a God as he wrote a
confession before taking the Elixir that
says that the being that created him was
no normal human given his father would
make sense that Simon was a God too
especially since his boss Soul says that
the boy was among those who were made to
live an immortal life however he was
deemed a failure and abandoned this
god-like being also gave him the ability
to read minds and by now we've heard
this mentioned a few times back at the
train station is the secret door that
has a letter from Simon addressed to us
where he says that he's able to read
minds and thanks us for being able to
find The Relic that he lost one of the
test subjects who managed to hide from
the monsters also says that he was
forced to consume Ergo in order to read
minds it's so bad that he can't even
think or dream about things it's just
constant thoughts of other people's
dreams the problem came when Simon's
father betrayed him and cast him out of
wherever he came from he felt hurt by
this and vowed to create a world where
no one can lie and he thinks that
summoning God can achieve this lots of
notes in this game seem to point to
Simon being more of a major player than
previously thought as the group's
version of a Bible is called so said
pistress and Simon's full name is Simon
pistries Manus now I'm definitely
willing to believe that Simon is that
egotistical to name the group's text
after himself but I do wonder if the
One-Winged Angel San Frangelico saw was
Simon a one-waned angel symbolized an
angel cast out of heaven and Simon was
cast out by his father where it starts
to get a little rocky though is that
item he carries with him called the arm
of God it's implied that this name is no
figure of speech but the literal arm of
a God who came to Earth and shed his
bodies that Humanity could be immortal
part of me wants to believe that this
was Simon's arm who somehow managed to
then infiltrate a group that was
worshiping him but I'm not too confident
in that theory either way Simon's main
goal is to become immortal and prevent
the spread of Lies it's just a bit corny
I guess immortality has been an end goal
that's been used hundreds of times
across all media so it's not anything
unique where the difference lies is the
reasoning behind the immortality usually
it just ends up with the main villain
going I want to be immortal so I can
rule the world which is exactly what
Simon wants and that's pretty bland I do
like the part where he talks about
proving his father long but the rest is
quite boring the lying part is also
disappointing as it feels tacked on for
the sake of the fairy tale Pinocchio and
lying are synonymous but none of that
involves Simon I get the idea of
preventing lies because his father lied
and then betrayed him but it feels
shoehorned in at times because you can't
have a Pinocchio story without a heavy
emphasis on lying outside of that though
Simon himself is absent for about 90 of
the story I mean think about how much
time we've actually spent talking about
him we've barely interacted with him or
his group the only three Alchemists we
meet are the door guardian laxasia and
Simon and all that happens in the last
three hours of the game most of his
villainy comes from his actions rather
than his presence and I will admit it
does work at times like with Victor or
the victims of the cathedral but I feel
like you need to be more present in the
script
with Simon dead though the Alchemists
have been defeated and crot is saved but
when we go down below the arena we're
greeted by Geppetto he congratulates us
on defeating Simon as is it with the arm
of God we can become human again all we
need to do is give him our heart and
we'll become a real boy when he says we
though he's not talking about us he's
talking about who we look like Carlo if
you obey then you're given the bad
ending where Geppetto rips out our heart
and place it in the body of another
puppet he and the new Carlo then
returned to the hotel before packing
their things and leaving but as we go we
see the dead bodies of Eugenie venini
and puccinella and when we gain back
control we see that our friends have now
become puppets if we however refuse then
we have to fight the puppet that's in
the Box it's another two-phase fight
where the puppet starts using blood
related attacks that I swear I've seen
before
according to the achievement this
nameless puppet was the first puppet
Geppetto ever made to possibly meaning
that Carlo's death and his plan to
revive him was what got him into making
puppets in the first place
but during the scuffle Jupiter were
revealed to us that Pinocchio was never
a part of the grand Covenant like the
other puppets because we still have
Carlos memories inside of us one thing
I'm still puzzled about though is that
puppet frenzy as I don't recall the game
ever bringing this up again after the
fight with Romeo which makes me question
why Gepetto did it to begin with
Romeo has no reason to lie to us and if
he's telling the truth why would
Geppetto start the frenzy and then ask
us to stop Romeo at the end of it all
all he wants to do is revive his son but
how does the puppet frenzy accomplish
that Geppetto apparently needed a vast
amount of Ergo as well as the arm of God
in order to achieve this he never states
where that source of Ergo is coming from
though as the tower is not only filled
with it thanks to us defeating the
bosses but we also have a ton of it
inside of us due to leveling up plus he
didn't even know Pinocchio was alive
until we found him since Sofia was the
one who revived us not him he also
doesn't seem to want Croc destroyed
either as after this ending he talks
about dealing with the rest of the
puppets in the petrification disease
Romeo once again could be lying to us
but I really can't imagine he would as
he has no reason to genuinely do let me
know if I missed something here because
I don't recall this ever being
elaborated on again but I could be wrong
in a way though I do kind of respect his
motives as at its core it's really just
a father who wants his son back but
seeing his Pinocchio was essentially
made to be an organ donor for the real
Carlo We're not gonna let him do that it
also showcases a flaw in Geppetto's
thinking as he could have had his son
the whole time had he just treated
Pinocchio like one instead of seeing him
as the puppet who would have saved his
son's life this idea of Pinocchio being
a real boy is also what decides our
ending all throughout the game we're
given the choice to lie or tell the
truth telling the truth gives us the
good ending where right at the end of
the fight the puppet goes for the
killing blow before being stopped by
Geppetto as the puppet started having a
mind of its own and realized that it was
going to destroy Pinocchio's heart which
would have ruined Geppetto's plan in the
good ending Pinocchio then holds
Geppetto in his final moments as he
curses him for just being another puppet
if you've been lying throughout the
whole game though then you get the true
ending where Geppetto realizes that he
was wrong and that Pinocchio was always
the son he wanted as he sees a single
tear fall from his cheek showing that he
is now officially a real boy he then
goes back up the tower and somehow
magically makes a puppet with blue hair
and ergos I didn't give Sophia a at life
I know I called her Ronnie as a joke
earlier but this is starting to become a
bit uncanny it seems like Pinocchio dies
here but when we go back to the hotel we
get a letter from Sophia Thanking us for
Reviving her what I assume happened is
he just collapsed from exhaustion due to
his body now becoming human and catching
up with all the stress that he put on it
throughout the game but I could be wrong
regardless of what ending you get though
and after credit cutscene shows giangio
talking with someone he claims that the
crotch disaster was an experiment and
that a new brother was born into eternal
life likely referring to us giangio also
seems to be an alchemist as when we talk
to Paul and Dean about getting a cure to
save lady Antonia he says that a
well-known Alchemist might be able to
help her but the person who gives us the
Cure is giangio possibly implying that
he's a part of their organization also
his other name according to the cutscene
is paracelsus who is an actual Alchemist
in real life
the last line has one of the more
interesting implications though as
giangio claims that his next Target is a
girl named Dorothy before showing a
scene of a girl with red heels walking
on a rooftop and crot I assume this is
the Dorothy he's talking about and if so
the only Dorothy I know of with red
shoes is the one from The Wizard of Oz
if that's true this means that couple
with Pinocchio gianjo and his companions
are hunting down main characters from
other fairy tales I don't want to say
this is fact but there are way too many
coincidences for that not to be either
way this thing with Dorothy is likely
setting up a future DLC for the game but
at the moment we have no news on if or
when that will be released with that
though we have now come to the end of
lies of p a fairy tale Souls like that
has quite a mysterious story let me know
what you think about the game in the
video in the comments down below also
let me know what ending you got if you
played the game as always like the view
if you do enjoy and subscribe if you're
new check out my other star related
content on the channel if this video
interests you thinking about returning
viewers coming back to another video and
take care everyone
goodbye